playoffs your big Yankee fans you must
have gone to some big games in your day
Oh a bunch of big games sure I I went to
the World Series in 1977 Reggie Jackson
at the three home runs you were at that
I was at that game how'd you get to that
guy I was 10 years old my old man who
you know he installed the antennas
Verlinden have a lot of money buddy he
sent away for tickets and he got tickets
in the mail 10 bucks apiece I still have
the ticket stubs last row of the upper
deck for game 6 of the 77 series Reggie
it's the 3 home runs and it shows you
how times are different my father was a
street guy he was a north guy and this
actually happened so at the end of the
game were in the upper deck and it looks
at the action gonna win they're up by 4
runs and in the old days when your team
on the world series at home the fans
could charge the field they were allowed
to you know they weren't allowed to but
cops just said the hell with it right
knocked a few guys out and everybody
went on the field yeah who could get on
the field but they knocked only adults
out right they wouldn't touch anybody
else and my father was smart he knew
that so we leave the upper deck my back
then you could you know dupe the guy's
$5 they bring and these guys were
bringing down to the very first row and
that's the difference in the nowadays
the the wealthy sophisticated people
stayed till the end in the old days only
the scumbags stay and we snuck our way
up to where they you know rich people
were sitting in a very we were very
first row of the game for the last out
so the Yankees are about to make the
last bounce and we're looking right I'm
a 10 years old I can't believe so my
father was like Superman to me so he
actually did it this is how I was raised
before the last dad he goes to me
whispers like this listen when they make
the last out I'm not gonna be able to
run on the field I'm like okay he goes
but you can and I'm like all right as
soon as they make the last out I'm gonna
throw you on the field throw you okay
now I'm 10 years old he's I'm like you
know
and he goes I just run the shortstop
stay there eventually you know the cops
are not gonna be able to hit everybody
I'll wait you know get the shorts not
just wait for me to meet you in like 20
minutes
so I'm ten years old mate that sounds
great or a fighter so Lee lacy on the
Dodgers he squares to bunt
Mike Torres was a pitcher for the
Yankees he caught the bumper a pop up to
the pitcher he caught it him in the
Yankee catcher Thurman Munson
they they they embrace like that's it
there's a second that goes by and I
think I'm off the hook with that my
father puts his hand on the bottom of my
back like he's shooting a free throw
which was in my ear
I mean shortstop he throws another field
tumble saw I look up and he he goes
wrong runner shortstop and I run and the
footage people are running all over the
place
yeah people look like Reggie Jackson was
hitting people because he was afraid
they were gonna steal something from him
yeah somebody stole Willie Randolph's
hat right off his head
cops were just hitting anybody to look
like a hippie and everybody looked like
they were in Led Zeppelin I can't see my
father you know what I felt like I felt
like you know the end of platoon where
the helicopter leaves Willem Dafoe yes
[Laughter]
I weren't the shortstop and I'm waiting
there like ten minutes go by fifteen
minutes goes by twenty and I'm starting
to cry now like you know but I feel tap
on my shoulder and this is classic my
old man I turn around to my father and
he puts me on you know and then he
leaned over to me and he said listen
don't worry about tomorrow no matter
what your mother says you don't have to
go to school that's the last time I ever
went to school
[Applause]